welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and guardians of the galaxy volume 3
yippee
so stupid rocket raccoon and his amazing
friends recently hit san diego comic-con
over the weekend with new comic-con
exclusive footage of what is sure to be
one of the most emotional marvel movies
we will ever witness through wet
eyeballs and with amazing director and
friend james gunn saying that guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 will be the final
chapter of the guardians as we know them
i'm gonna need marvel studios to release
the comic-con trailer online yesterday
please because hoarding baby rocket
raccoon footage is just wrong kevin it's
wrong but until then let us talk about
that sweet guardians of the galaxy vol 3
footage at hall 8 shall we my nerd
babies but before we do make sure you
hit up new rockstarsmerch.com to check
out our newest latest obsession shirt
inspired by thor love and thunder it's
not going to be around for long so
please buy it today before it disappears
forever but if you don't want to buy
that we have tons and tons of other
amazing merch options over there so hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com today all
right guys so this trailer set to the
super emotional version of do you
realize by the flaming lips opens up
with the guardianship confronted by a
group of ravager space pirates and the
guardians freaking the f out only to
find out that those ravagers were being
led by none other than the deadliest
woman in the galaxy herself the very
same time displaced gamora from avengers
end game who nebula apparently has made
an appointment with without telling her
fellow guardians teammates which is you
know likely why they were taken by
surprise and freaking out because their
ship was being approached by this huge
ravager ship and having gamora leading
her own factions of ravagers like yondu
did makes sense considering where we
last left her in avengers end game
because in that movie gamora teamed up
with a bunch of random ravagers who
portaled in via doctor strange portal
from contractia to fight her father's
army and so after that fight i can
definitely see her leaving with those
ravagers and then using her lifetime of
training to become the deadliest woman
in the andromeda galaxy to make herself
a fellow ravager leader alongside the
likes of stakhar aylida and charlie 27
from guardians of the galaxy volume 2.
after her father and his friends were
turned into breathable dust particles
she kinda had nowhere to go and no
family to call her own as this gamora is
a multiverse variant who has never
bonded with the guardians with gamora
even saying the words that person wasn't
me after peter tells her that he misses
her and that she meant everything to him
while footage of their close romantic
moments from the first two films played
mainly that moment where they were
listening to music together on nowhere
and when they were dancing together on
ego's planet which is super harsh to
hear after you know peter doomed the
half the universe to punch her killer in
the face and after she shatters peter's
heart into a million pieces the gamora
and the guardians all do a super
dramatic space hop in multi-colored
spacesuits that look a lot like the
advanced crew escape suits that nasa
used for a very long time and one that
the collector actually has in his
collection in guardians of the galaxy
vol 1. which makes me think that the
collector may have found it whenever the
collector ran into cosmo the space dock
who james gunn has revealed at comic con
will be voiced by the talented maria
bakalova from the sequel to borat but
hey speaking of rats that aren't really
all that bow the comic-con trailer also
had the most adorable shot of a
terrified baby rat version of rocket
that you have ever seen watching a big
old hand about to grab him and perform
experiments on him a hand that no doubt
belongs to a man that i have long
suspected to be rocket raccoon's abusive
creator the high evolutionary played by
peacemakers chakuri owuji who actually
landed the role of the high evolutionary
because of his amazing work on
peacemaker now the reason why i call
baby rocket a baby rat in this trailer
and not a baby raccoon is because rocket
is canonically not a raccoon in the mcu
james gunn has stated for years now that
rocket is a raccoon-like lower life form
evolved and cybernetically enhanced to
look like a bipedal raccoon much like a
florkin is in a cat's whatever rat
species rocket used to be are not
raccoons even though they look like
raccoons and the reason why this is
significant is because the high
evolutionary got his very start in
evolving beings through his
experimentations on rats evolving those
rats into bipedal animals with thoughts
and feelings and named those animals his
new men basically is his newer and
better versions of human beings and he
would create a different planet for them
called counter-earth where they would
live much like normal human beings did
but in a weird animalistic type of way
they had their own societies the
mirrored community societies a lot so
that hand reaching into the cage is
likely to be the beginnings of rocket
raccoons torture at the hands of the
evolution obsessed herbert windham the
high evolutionary which is further
underscored by a shot of someone writing
the letters 89p13 on some glass which is
rocket raccoon's original subject name
followed by a super creepy shot of a
small surgical buzzsaw that definitely
gives credence to james gunn's claim of
rocket being quote the saddest character
in the universe because those scars on
rocket's back definitely came from
somewhere and then somewhere is likely
the high evolutionary but i will get
into specifically how the high
evolutionary made rocket raccoon in a
later video because it's actually quite
interesting it has its roots in several
different marvel projects it's really
fun but one of the trailers dopest
moments came with our first shot of will
poulter's adam warlock looking ultra
amazing and comics accurate this dude is
gold as [ __ ] and even has what appears
to be a soul stone or a spot for a soul
stone in the center of his forehead to
complete his super comic accurate look
and speaking of comics accurate if you
yourself were waiting all these years
for the guardians of the galaxy to wear
their original blue and red costumes
from their initial marvel comics
appearance feel free to rejoice because
shots of peter quill drax and the rest
of the guardians wearing the original
guard in the galaxy uniforms can be seen
through the trailer along with what
looks like a young adult groot
absolutely tearing [ __ ] up with his
uncle peter but the guardians having
uniforms make sense considering that we
do get this really quick shot of nebula
in front of a gold neon sign with alien
text that translates to guardians of the
galaxy which is literally the very same
neon gold logo of the movie it's like
they took that sign changed the letters
to english and that was the logo so it
seems like the guardians now have a
physical location where they can accept
jobs and so wearing uniforms helps them
feel like a legitimate band of
mercenaries rather than you know your
common ruthless space ravager but that
is it for this quick recap of the
guardians 3 footage that debuted at san
diego comic con 2022. i pray to the
evolutionary on high that marvel studios
finds it in their hearts to release that
amazing trailer online in full hd
because my god does james gunn know how
to tug at the heartstrings man like i
already know that i am not going to be
okay during this movie but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but most importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and when you do on youtube
make sure you hit that notification bell
so that you can get notifications every
time we upload a video but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching i love you
guys so so much and remember that we
are root don't forget it see you guys
later
[Music]
so
[Music]
you